zum ersten mal wird es möglich sein das
seltsame verhalten des sterns kec 846
2852 in ecuador wachen er verdunkelt
sich in unregelmäßigen zeitabständen und
das in einer stärke die absolut
rätselhaft mich für sein verhalten gibt
es keine natürliche erklärung bisher
weshalb wissenschaftler dort eine alien
mega struktur nicht ausschließen
was es damit auf sich hat jetzt den
blick zum 26 herzlich willkommen
84 wächst 2852 ist ein extrem weltweit
stern er macht etwas was kein stern den
wir hier von der erde aus beobachten
können macht er ändert seine helligkeit
auf eine art und weise für die die
wissenschaft einfach keine erklärung
findet außer aliens doch wie können sie
einen ganzen stern verdunkeln 3 nach der
stern wird als einer von 150000 sternen
vom weltraumteleskop kepler bei der
suche nach exoplaneten untersucht dabei
wird gemessen ob und wann sich der stern
verdunkelt was auf exoplaneten schließen
lässt geschieht dies regelmäßig immer
wieder gilt ein exo planeten als
gefunden und je nach sterben größe und
stärke der verdunklung der dauer der
verdunklung der frequenz und weiterer
daten können sogar rückschlüsse auf die
größe die bewohnbarkeit und weitere
eigenschaften geschlossen werden
geworden inzwischen schon nach heutigem
stand mehr als 3600 exo planeten
gefunden
doch bereits 84 62 85 macht etwas sehr
seltsames und noch wurde dafür keine
erklärung gefunden
der stern rund 150 lichtjahre entfernt
verdunkelt sich nur unregelmäßig und so
stark um bis zu 22 prozent
das astrophysiker jason wright von der
penn state university vermutet dass dort
eine ähnliche sensation für die
verdunklung verantwortlich seine ideen
mega strukturen wie die dyson sphäre
oder riesige satelliten schwärme zur
energiegewinnung sind so groß dass sie
das licht des jahren unregelmäßig abflug
bei der weißen fairer wäre eine solche
abdunklung sogar wahrscheinlich wenn sie
allerdings noch nicht fertig gestellt
wäre bei dieser affäre hätten die
bewohner des stern systems rund um den
stern oder zentralsterns eine schale
gebaut auf deren dem stern zugewandten
seite sich jetzt leben würden in der
nähe des äquators dinge dass wir gut da
hierdurch die rotation gravitation
simuliert wurde die fläche einer solchen
preisen wäre wäre hier in unserem
sonnensystem zum beispiel millionenfach
größer als die auf der erde eine solche
alien mega struktur könnte die strategie
sein um in einem fernen system als
intelligentes begriff zu überleben
allerdings hat die gezielte suche nach
radiosignalen aus dem k
cc 84 62 85 system mit babys zu keinem
ergebnis geführt so weit sein könnte
dass diese allen zivilisation gezielt
ihre funksignale up shop jetzt gibt es
aber erstmalig die chance die
verdunklung live zu beobachten
seit dem 19 mai wird k ii 8 4 625 wieder
dunkler seit ein paar tagen wird es von
3% und es wurde bereits mit
spektralanalysen begonnen
es scheinen objekt dem orbit es kam zu
sein so erst ergebnisse aber was so
riesig ist dass es einen stern so stark
ab dass weiß immer noch keiner sobald
das erste ergebnisse gibt der vater sehr
natürlich hier wenn ihr immer das
neueste zu kec 84 62 85 erfahren wollte
hier ein abo aufs auge unvergesslich den
auf die glocke damit er auf jeden fall
kein video verpasst hier geht es zum
video mit zehn gründen für die existenz
von aliens und ansonsten bugueño zu
sagen wissen bleibt